these British tanks in Estonia need to
be ready for action
threat from Russia is real and every
move counts
yeah so this is my uh challenge two main
battle tank uh of course 911 Bravo the
tanks are playing a passive role for now
part of a NATO mission to deter
aggression
but others are about to be sent to
Ukraine to help Ukrainian troops fight
Russia for real
so the challenge to itself was designed
specifically to fight Russian T-Series
main battle tanks so that with that in
mind I'm hoping that
it will go toe so it'll take a few
punches and dish out punches as it goes
the power of the punch may also depend
on whether german-made leopard tanks can
also join the battle
they're operated by several countries
but only Berlin can approve any
deployment to Ukraine and it's under
mounting pressure to say yes
Britain's defense secretary revealed
that one nation has formally requested
permission
I want as many tanks
to support the Ukrainian efforts in 2023
okay there's no secret about that you
know if we are to get a message to the
Kremlin that we're not giving up that we
are doubling down tanks are part of that
the UK was the first nation to announce
that it's sending Western tanks to
Ukraine 14 of these Challenger two main
battle tanks it's also going to be
sending 30 of these as90 guns the goal
is to equip the Ukrainian military with
the ability not just to defend their
territory but to launch more offensive
operations to push Russian forces out of
the country for good
the need to give weapons will dominate a
meeting in Germany tomorrow of around 50
Nations
all eyes will be on Berlin and what if
any signal it plans to make debraham Sky
News at tapa army base in Estonia